I think that's a very American question
I mean I think that many societies
wouldn't even pose it that way and it
reflects the fact that American history
although it's had its unfortunate
periods has been basically an incredibly
happy story again not for all Americans
but if you think of where the United
States began in 1776 and where it ended
up in 2007 it's a remarkable run of
success and it's partly because we did
some things right and it's also partly
because we got very lucky in where the
country was located the fact that the
native population turned out to be very
susceptible to disease that was brought
over from Europe the fact that the
European countries kept beating each
other up while we SAT here and became
more productive so we've been very
fortunate so we have this view of the
world that everything tends to go well
and therefore you're questioning how can
we solve all these problems so this
happy story continues well of course it
hasn't been as happy a story for you
know Russia throughout the 20th century
for much of Europe which destroyed
itself twice in the 20th century other
parts of the world don't tell white the
same happy story so I think the first
thing I would say is all right we
shouldn't be expecting perfection we're
not going to be solving all of these
problems and it's not like bad things
will never happen to Americans or to
other people we want to try to do the
best we can within the facing the set of
problems that we now face and with the
set of resources at our disposal the
sort of step one is be realistic about
what we think we can accomplish and then
start ticking off the various problems
I'm sorry working on them I think
Americans again tend to think of it as
sort of I want a perfect answer because
I'm an American citizen I'm entitled to
live for 85 years in relatively good
health and in a pretty comfortable house
with a pretty nice family that's not the
way it really works even in America